so I sit down and there's five people at
a time the only other people are five
people in this table and one of them's
George Clooney that's crazy get out of
here so then uh we eat and then so I go
to the bathroom and as I come out of the
bathroom George Clooney is like bowing
to him right he's like saying culture
Appropriations I've ever seen one I do
that now to him
we bow to each other when I leave we
bought each other so I and he's like
doing that and he's like saying
something to him so I like stop because
I don't want to walk in between them and
I just like I thought it'd be over real
quick but it they kept talking Anonymous
now it looks now I look like swipe I'm
standing there just because he's George
Clooney was anybody else I would just
walked right through so I'm like you cat
you got to walk through now you can't
just stand there you look like an idiot
so as I start to walk through and then I
ducked my head
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]